Teresa went skydiving.
The graph below discribes Teresa's height, measured in meters, as a function of time, measured in seconds.
So let's look at this graph over here. It's actually quite large, so let me zoom out a little bit.
And we can see that at time zero her height is seven hundred meters and then as time increases, as we move to the right her height is decreasing.
And her height is decreasing at faster and faster rates as we move to the right so her- her-
the rate of decline of her height is quite steep as we approach ten seconds after she jumps
And then we can see all of a sudden, then we can see all of a sudden her rate of decline slows down
She's still declining as -as we move forward in time, but she's declining at a slower rate.
And so we can say she's declining at a --- or she is --- her height is changing at a less negative rate
It's -It's quite a negative rate right over here --- seems roughly a fairly negative rate
but then it becomes a less negative rate right over here
her height is changing at a less negative rate
and it makes sense that this is when she deploys the parachute, so after 10 seconds
she deploys the parachute
so she jumps at 0 seconds, 10 seconds she deploys the parachute.
Alright so let's see what they're asking --- actually asking us.
They say
Complete the following sentence
Between 3 seconds and 8 seconds after Teresa jumped, her height decreased, on average, by approximately
blank meters per second.
So between 3 seconds, and 8 seconds, so at 3 seconds --- so time is 3 right over there
So, Let's see what H(3) is.
what is her height at 3 seconds and I'm just looking
at a graph so I'm going to have to
Ballpark it so at 3 seconds at 3 seconds
her height looks pretty close it's
pretty close we just have to approximate
it so her height at the height after 3
seconds it looks like it's about halfway
between 600 and 700 so it looks like
it's about 650 meters and then we care
between 3 seconds and 8 seconds so our
height at 8 seconds let's look at that
at 8 seconds let's see this looks about
halfway it looks about halfway between
350 between 350 and 400 so I'll say her
height at 8 seconds actually since I'm
approximating it let me put a little
squiggly equal sign here her height
after 8 seconds looks like it's
approximately 300 and looks
approximately 375 meters 375 meters so
what is her average rate of change her
height decreased on average by
approximately so we what we want to do
is we forgot to figure out the average
rate of change which you could view as
the slope of the line that connects
these two points the slope of this line
is going to be her average rate of
change so let's think about that her
average rate of change her change in
height over the change in time for that
interval well her change in height after
at 8 seconds she is at let me write it
this way her height at 8 seconds - her
height at 3 seconds so this is going to
be her change in height and the change
in time is 8 seconds she finishes at 8
seconds - where she started or the
interval that we care about starting at
3 seconds and so H of 8 we already said
this is approximately 375 H of 3 this is
650 and then of course 8 minus 3 is
going to be equal to 5
I just want emphasize this is just her
average rate of change for approximate
average rate of change over this
interval as we as we go from 3 to 8
seconds our height goes from H of 3 to H
of 8 so this is going to be let's see
375 - 650
let's see if it was 375 - 675 it would
be negative 300 and so this is going to
be but then we're not subtracting 675
we're subtracting 650 so it's going to
be 25 it's going to be 25 more so this
is going to be negative 275 over 5 let
me make sure I did that math right let
me make sure I did that math right so
it's 375 - 650 is
negative 275 does that make sense
let's see 275 plus 375 would be 2 650
yeah that is right all right so let's
just figure out what this is so 5 I'll
just figure out what 5 goes into 275 and
then we can remember the negative 5 goes
into 27 5 times 5 times 5 is 25
subtract we get a to bring down to 5 5
goes into 25 five times and then we're
not going to have a remainder so this is
going to be equal to negative 55
negative 55 and the unit's our height is
given in meters so this part up here
this is in meters up here meters per
second so her change in height or
average change in height over or the
average rate of change of height over
this five seconds over this five seconds
is negative 55 meters per second one way
to think about it the slope right over
here the slope is equal to negative
55 now it might be tempting to just
write negative 55 right over here but
let's just think about whether that
would be right between 3 seconds and 8
seconds after Teresa jumped her height
decreased on average by approximately
negative 55 meters per second and
decrease is important because they're
already saying that it's decreased when
this negative is telling us that we're
decreasing we're decreasing at a rate of
55 meters per second our average rate of
change is a decrease our average rate of
high a change of height over time is a
decrease of 55 meters per second well
the negative is already saying the
decrease so we're not decreasing at a
negative rate of change we would be
decreasing at 55 meters per second so
let me just write it 55 meters per
second if they asked if they asked her
height if we asked her height if we if
they asked the average change of height
average rate of change let me write this
the average rate of change of change of
H over or let me say of H from 3 seconds
3 seconds
to 8 seconds
well now this would be negative 55
meters per second but when they're
saying that her height decrease that's
re taking the negative into
consideration they're saying it's
definitely decreasing that's what the
negatives already telling us it's
decreasing by a rate of 55 meters per
second hopefully that makes some sense